En este video nos vamos a enfocar en sucesiones
que espero que hayas visto. Si no sabes qué es una
sucesión, te invito a que revises los videos de
Khan Academy sobre el tema. Esta vez nos vamos a
enfocar en cómo podemos generar la misma sucesión
con diferentes funciones que tienen diferentes
dominios, así que comencemos con una sucesión
de ejemplo. Digamos que tenemos esta sucesión: 6,
a éste le llamamos el primer término -algunas
personas lo llaman término 0-, éste es el primer
término, después el segundo término es 12, luego
24, 48 y así sucesivamente, y como veremos hay
múltiples definiciones de funciones con las que
podríamos crear una sucesión. Una forma de pensar
en esto es que 6 = 6 • 1, esto es 6 • 2, 6 • 4, 6
• 8, así que parece que cada término es igual a 6
por una potencia de 2. Déjenme aclararlo: esto
es 6 • 2⁰, que es igual a 6 • 1; este término
es 6 • 2¹, este término es 6 • 2², 6 • 4; este
término es 6 • 2³. Y una forma de verlo es que
si consideramos que este es el término 0 podríamos
definir una función a(n), en donde n se refiere a
nuestro índice o al término de nuestra sucesión,
y es igual a 6 • 2 a la n, donde n comienza en 0
y luego sigue incrementándose en 1, de modo que en
realidad son todos los enteros mayores o iguales
a 0. Es muy importante especificar ese dominio
donde n es un entero y n es mayor o igual que 0.
Podríamos ver qué sucede si n no es un número
entero, si tratamos de poner 1.5 o algo así,
entonces no vamos a obtener uno de los términos
de la sucesión, y si no comenzamos en 0,
si comenzamos en 1, entonces este sería el primer
término en la sucesión, que no es lo que queremos,
queremos generar la sucesión que escribimos
originalmente. Y obviamente si comenzamos con
n = -1, entonces obtendríamos un valor diferente
para el primer término, de modo que esta es una
forma de definir o crear una función que
genera esta sucesión. Pero como veremos,
hay otras formas de hacerlo, por ejemplo,
déjenme escribir otra. Digamos que tengo b(n),
y digamos que en lugar de comenzar con n igual a 0
-y podríamos ver esto como el término 0- queremos
comenzar con n = 1, entonces lo que podemos hacer
es que cuando ingresemos un 1 esto esencialmente
se convierte en un 0. ¿Cómo podemos hacer eso?
Bueno, restémosle 1, así que podríamos decir:
6(2) a la potencia n -1, donde n es un entero y n
≥ 1. Fíjense, ahora cuando ponemos n= 1 aquí, tal
vez podríamos decir que este es el primer término,
queremos generar un 6, ¿qué es lo que sucede?
1 - 1, obtenemos la potencia 0 que queremos justo
aquí, y así 6 • 2⁰ sin duda es igual a 6. Luego,
cuando n = 2, tenemos 6 • 2 a la n menos uno,
que es igual a 2¹, se convierte en 6 • 2, lo
que equivale a 12. Observa: estas son definiciones
de funciones diferentes con diferentes dominios,
pero están generando exactamente la misma
sucesión. También podríamos hacerlo de forma
recursiva; hemos hecho esto en otros videos,
podemos definir una función de forma recursiva.
Podríamos decir que cada uno de los términos de
nuestra sucesión es el doble del término anterior,
si queremos una definición recursiva para la
sucesión, podemos definir el primer término,
o, en este caso, podríamos decir el término 0, si
queremos comenzar con n = 0; t(0) = 6 y podríamos
decir t(n) = 2 t(n - 1), donde n es un entero y n ≥
0. Esto también genera la sucesión. Cuando ponemos
n = 0 aquí, obtenemos este término; cuando tenemos
n = 1, t(1) = 2 t(n - 1), t(0) en ese caso, sería
2 t(0) = 6, 2 • 6 = 12. Ahora, si quisiéramos
generar el 6 cuando n = 1, podemos hacerlo de esta
manera: en lugar de decir que t(0) = 6 podríamos
escribir que t(1) = 6, pero ahora tendríamos que
escribir un dominio diferente, donde n tiene
que ser un número entero, n es un entero,
y ahora en lugar de decir n ≥ 0, ahora n ≥ 1.
Esperemos que este video logre mostrar que hay
múltiples formas, ya sea con una función explícita
tradicional o con una función recursiva como esta.
En cualquiera de estos casos podríamos tener
diferentes dominios y diferentes definiciones de
funciones que generan la misma sucesión, pero
realmente tenemos que pensar en el dominio.